PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Hi.
I'm Priyanka Vergadia, and this
is "AI Simplified," where we
learn to make our data useful.
In this video, we are
predicting the future.
That sounds like I'm an
astrologer, but not really.
We are going to predict a
different kind of future
influenced by data.
Yeah, you're right, we're
covering forecasting models--
what they are and how to
create them in Vertex Forecast.
But before we dive
into it, what are
some of the applications
of forecasting?
Say you're a
retailer and you need
to predict product
demand or sales,
or you're a call center manager
and you're predicting the call
volume to hire more
representatives,
you're a hotel chain
predicting hotel occupancy
for next season, or you're a
hospital and forecasting bed
occupancy.
You get the idea.
Forecasting data sets come
in many shapes and sizes.
There are univariate
data sets, where
we observe a single variable
over a period of time.
For example, you can think about
weather data or airlines data.
Even though it's
just one variable,
sometimes this is all
that you need to forecast
your data into the future.
You can see clear patterns,
the seasonal peaks, and also
the trends in that data.
More often, we are faced
with multivariate data sets,
where you have historical
observations of the variables
you're forecasting and
other related time series.
These are often referred to
as covariates, and covariates,
because the value varies
with the target variable.
These related time series can
be very helpful to forecast
your target variable.
And maybe, for example, you're
plotting rain versus umbrella
sales versus Uber rides.
Now, we all know how taxis can
be hard to get when it suddenly
starts to rain.
So as an owner of
a taxi company,
I can use the weather forecast
to anticipate the higher
demand in my cars and
bring the cars online.
Be aware that not all
covariates are useful,
even if they correlate strongly
with your target variable.
Some common examples
of covariates
used in retail forecasting are
holidays, third-party forecasts
such as weather,
and you can have
planned promotions, foot traffic
to the stores, and so on.
Up next, we are going to look
at forecasting algorithms.
Now, here are the algorithms
we can use for forecasting.
The most popular methods
today are statistical methods,
which are also called
as classical methods.
There are many types
of statistical models,
including ARIMA models, that are
being used for most popular use
cases.
Now, Google offers an
advanced ARIMA plus model
with BQML, which is BigQuery ML.
The other class is
machine learning models,
like various tree-based
methods and neural networks.
Now, these deep
learning models have
been gaining a lot of popularity
for forecasting applications
over the past few years.
Now, obviously,
there's still a lot
of debate on when to
apply which methods,
but it's becoming
increasingly clear
that neural networks
are here to stay
for forecasting applications.
These methods
perform fairly well
across a broad range of
forecasting problems,
and particularly well when
dealing with forecasting
newer item demands.
And these are
called cold starts,
and forecasting cold starts on
items with limited or varying
historical data.
Now, deep learning
models cross-learn
across very large groups
of related time series
with varying lengths
and missing data.
The good news is
that you don't really
need to know exactly
which architecture to use
because Vertex Forecast
does that for you.
Now, we can build
forecasting models
in Vertex using advanced auto
ML algorithms for neural network
architecture search.
Now, we automated the
preprocessing of your time
series data, and, instead
of fumbling into data types
and transformations,
you can just
load your data into the
data set in Vertex AI,
and auto ML would
automatically apply
those common transformations
and even engineer features
for you required for modeling.
Now, most importantly,
we could evaluate
hundreds of models in parallel
to find the right architecture
for your particular data set.
And this requires a lot of
computational resources.
But because we can run all
these trials in parallel,
we're still able to
find the best model
and tune it to your
particular data
set in the fraction
of time it typically
takes for a traditional method.
And of course, we can
assemble the best model
and together to
ensure the model is
stable across a wide range
of predicted outputs.
Now, how does all this work?
Let's jump into the
console and see.
From our Vertex AI dashboard, we
create a new tabular data set.
We can see there is an
option for forecasting.
You may be curious if you
can apply a regression
model to your time series data.
Now, the difference
between them is
that regression and
classification, the target's
predictive value depends only
on the values of the feature
columns in the same row.
Now, in forecasting, the
target's predictive value
also depends on
the context values
of the target and the features.
Now, we will see more on
this further in the demo.
In regression and
classification problems,
the output is one value.
But as you can imagine,
in forecasting problems,
the output is a
sequence of values.
Now let's select Forecasting
here and proceed.
We are using the Iowa Liquor
Sales public dataset available
in BigQuery.
Now, it consists of wholesale
liquor purchases in the United
States state of Iowa
since 2012, and we
can preview this data here.
For the purpose of this
demo, I have already
done some basic data
preprocessing to group
the purchases by
day, and we will
use a CSV extract from
the BigQuery table.
Now, back in our data
set, let's import the data
from our Cloud Storage bucket.
You can also upload the data
directly from your computer
or BigQuery table here.
Once the data is
imported, we can
configure the model features.
The time series
identify column is
to specify what time
series a row belongs to.
Now, every unique
combination of key values
defines a different time series.
For example, here in ID is
our time series identifier.
Now, if we need to
forecast on multiple time
series, such as product and
store levels, both of those
could be used as keys.
Now, time column is the
identifier, such as date
or days, et cetera.
Y is our sum of
purchases that day,
and holiday is a Boolean
to indicate a holiday.
Then we can train the model.
Select the target column.
This is the value
we are predicting.
So in our case, it is
sales, or the Y column.
We have already set our time
series identifier and the time
column, so next we need to
set the date of frequency.
I'm selecting hourly here and
setting the forecasting horizon
to 7.
This specifies the
number of periods
that the model can
predict into the future.
Now, historical context window
I'm setting to 30 hours here.
This means that the model will
use data from previous 30 hours
to make a prediction.
There are trade-offs between
shorter and longer windows,
and generally selecting a
value between 1 to 5 times
the forecasting
horizon is recommended.
Now let's check
the box to export
test data set to BigQuery.
We can leave it blank,
and it will automatically
create a data set and table in
our project within BigQuery.
Now, in the training options,
we can specify more details
about how we would like
to train the model.
Set these columns to
available for a new forecast
because we know this
information already.
Change the optimization
objective to MAE,
or Mean Average Error, which
is more resilient to outliers.
And because we are working
with daily purchase data that
can have wild fluctuations,
MAE is an appropriate metric
to use here.
Before we initiate the
training, set a budget.
In this case, one node hour is
sufficient to train the model.
Now, once the model
is trained, we
can evaluate it and
go to BigQuery console
to view the predictions
on test data.
Our new data set
is automatically
created where we find the
evaluated data items table
to review the predictions.
This table has a couple
of new columns here--
the Predicted on
Date column, which
is the date that the predictions
were made, and Predicted Y
column is the
predicted sales value.
Now, finally, we would
want to use your model
to make predictions.
We have an input file in the
CSV format on Cloud Storage,
and it contains MT
values for the dates
to be predicted along
with the historical data.
After it is complete, we can
click on the batch prediction
job to view the details,
including the export location.
We sent our predictions
to BigQuery,
which we can see here, and the
job creates two different files
or tables.
One contains any
rows with errors,
and the other
contains predictions.
Lastly, now that we have
our batch predictions ready,
we can evaluate our
forecasts in Data Studio,
which is Google's free
data visualization tool.
The blue line shows
my historical values,
and the red lines
are my forecast.
Now, it looks like
the model picked up
on quite a bit of
signal in the data.
So in this video, we learned
about forecasting models,
what they are, and how to
create them in Vertex Forecast.
Give this a try yourself,
and send me your questions
in the comments below.